(audience cheering)
- I'm such a big fan.
- I'm a fan.
- [Kelly] Oh ditto.
- It's Kelly Clarkson
ladies and gentlemen.
- I'm not joking about that either.
I literally, I was like,
what is this thing?
And you've got mail.
I remember when it came out and I saw it
and I was obsessed with typewriters.
- [Greg] Oh yeah.
- [Kelly] Yes. That's when my obsession--
- You were like a lone reed.
One of the great Nora
Ephron lines of all time.
Me wooing Meg Ryan.
- [Kelly] What a great character.
- Well I'm a fan of yours.
Honestly, I feel like Kelly Clarkson
is my fourth daughter.
- [Kelly] What?
- Yes.
- I'm not even, I'm too old
to be a daughter of yours.
- I about like 20
whatever, however long ago that was,
you had your meteoric rise.
- Oh, 20 years ago.
- Was it? It was 20 years ago.
We were at maximum stress point.
We had a lot of kids.
I guess it technically is only
three daughters, but it felt like 30.
- That's a lot.
- Yes. And they were like
ages, you know, young.
Just the time where they
are sticking fingers
in light plugs and everything.
And when you could get them to bed,
and when you could
finally find some solace
and you know, I'd sit down with my wife.
I'd have a little cocktail.
Little cocktail.
And we would watch that show
and just watch you crush it.
And I believe we voted for you.
- Well, I'm gonna take
it like that anyway.
(crowd cheering)
That's so nice.
- It's crazy that it's 20 years ago,
but you're musical as well.
Cause I've seen you sing in movies.
- Oh stop.
- I've seen it.
So stop.
No do you love, did you ever think about
going into music or have a band
or anything when you were like younger?
- You feel threatened?
- I feel threatened.
No, I feel challenged that maybe
there's a duet in our future.
- Oh my gosh, is that happening?
Are we finally doing this thing?
- This is finally gonna happen.
It could be from Greg to Kelly.
- I did a movie with Matt Damon about
these conjoined twins back
when everyone in Hollywood
was making movies about conjoined twins.
And it was this comedy, the
Farrelly brothers did it.
And at the end of the movie,
we get separated and my dream,
Matt's an introvert and I'm an extrovert.
And I have this dream of
doing musical theater.
So Meryl Streep and I perform a number.
And the director says, "Hey,
listen I need you to record,
I need you to butcher
Billy Stewart's incredible
1966 version of Summertime."
So I actually did a full recording of it.
And so eventually,
I get a call from my lawyer.
This is years later, the movie didn't,
you know perform very well.
But years later I get a call,
a couple years later of ago
I get a call from my
lawyer who says "Rihanna."
- What?
- That's right.
"Rihanna wants to use a part
of your song in her album."
She wants to kinda, I
guess it's called a--
- Rihanna sampled you?
That is amazing.
- She sampled. Yeah.
- [Kelly] I've never been sampled.
- Yeah. So I'm sampled.
- Yeah. People that are
sampled are awesome.
- I thought we were gonna
like be on the road together.
(laughs)
I thought we had a whole thing.
I never talked to her again.
She just used it in this song
in one of the albums.
So it was cool yeah.
- Greg and Rihanna. Gregory.
It's got a nice combo to it.
- Kind of like a shorter Gregory.
I like it, I like it.
Were your daughters,
do they freak out that
you're on a Rihanna song?
- You know, honestly
the song was slightly--
- [Kelly] Inappropriate?
- Yeah, NR. It was mature audiences only.
So I didn't hear it for years.
And then now I think they're
kinda just discovering it now.
- So wait this got even cooler.
You got sampled on an X-rated song?
This is so much cooler.
That's awesome.
So wait I have to ask, in
"Little Miss Sunshine"--
I love that movie. Everyone does.
Were you really driving the car? The van?
- Yes. That is not there apparently.
It looks like I'm a little bored there.
(mumbles)
You can count every Michael
Bay movie ever made,
this is the most dangerous film ever made.
We didn't have, nobody
was wearing seat belts.
We didn't have clearance on the highway.
We just went out and they handed me--
Cause I drive in the thing.
They're like, here's the keys.
- Like they won't even let
me do that in the (mumbles)
no one can be in the car in like a voicing
if we're like doing a like
skip forward or something.
Like it's such a liability.
- Yes.
I'm interviewing you during Covid
on the other side of a couch right now.
(laughs)
Nobody is making this
movie anymore is my point.
- I love that though.
That would've made me nervous
driving that whole cast.
It's a solid cast too.
So you're like, hope I don't mess this up.
- Oh my God.
There's millions of dollars of cargo
in this vehicle for God's sake.
- I would not have liked that
pressure is what I'm saying.
So can you tell us what
"Shining Vale" is about?
The house is beautiful by the way.
- It is gorgeous.
- Yes. It's a gorgeous house.
- We shot that out in South Pasadena,
and then Warner Brothers amazingly
rebuilt this exact replica
of this enormous house
over about three or four sound stages
at Warner Brothers and
did an incredible job.
But it's this story of
this family,
I play the father.
Courtney Cox, my lovely
wife, America's sweetheart.
There she is ladies and gentlemen.
(crowd cheering)
We live in New York City
and she's had a little
bit of an indiscretion.
And we've had a little bit
of stress in the family.
She used to write kind of these, you know
those kind of books,
like fifty shades of--
- Oh naughty books. Naughty books.
- Yeah naughty books. That lady porn.
- [Kelly] Yes, lady porn.
- And she kinda had a hit
and now she's kind of stuck.
So she has writer's block.
We move out to the country
to this little town
in Connecticut called Shining Vale.
And I get this enormous house
for $300,000 below asking.
And we move into it and
she starts to either
have menopause or starts to see something.
And we're not sure, I'm
not sure what's happening.
But there is a spirit,
there is, in the house.
It's some comedy with drama,
it's drama with comedy.
It's a really interesting tone.
The show creators did an incredible job.
It was great fun to do.
And I haven't gotten to
do horror stuff for ever.
So it's great.
- I love that it ties in both.
That it's like horror and
there's stuff happening,
but also there's a lot of comedy.
Like your sarcasm, just
seeping in that scene alone,
was amazing.
- Oh thanks.
- And how the daughter,
she's like don't be scared.
She's like, I'm solid.
She's like, I love it.
It's such a teenager.
So ever had any supernatural
experiences like in your life?
- I have not.
I know everybody has ghost stories.
Does everybody have ghost stories?
Anybody have like a serious--
A smattering of applause.
Not as many ghost people here at the
Kelly Clarkson show as I would've thought.
- I think it can be explained.
I think I'm cynical.
I don't believe or not believe.
I just, I think I've had some
stuff happen but I'm like,
that's probably an old house
or probably like whatever.
- I'm exactly the same.
I don't believe in, you know
gnomes and elves and fairies.
So ghosts kind of fit in that box.
but I have enough people who have
told me these stories where I'm like, wow.
That's a pretty convincing story.
I know people that you never would expect
to have something like
this you know, go down.
So I guess I stay open to it, but no,
no great ghost story for you.
- I feel like there's
like enough happening
in this realm to deal with.
That like why invite other realms in?
- Like we really haven't nailed this one.
(audience applause)
- I'm scared enough right now.
I don't need, I don't need another.
I don't need that.
- Are you serious?
So wait, Courtney Cox said that
you'd mess with her on set.
Are you a prankster? Is this true?
- I'm not really a prankster.
She's really very, very easy
to scare as it turns out.
So, and I didn't know that.
And I, you know, I adore
Courtney is wonderful
and it was so, I had done an
episode of "Friends" years ago.
But we didn't really get to work together
I've just had so much fun on the show.
But yeah, you can scare the
bejesus out of Courtney.
Just at any time, anywhere.
So I use that to great effect.
- Did I hear that you
actually scared her for real,
and then they ended up using it?
- Yes, actually, if you watch the trailer
for "Shining Vale,"
it's on the stars thing,
and if you watch it you'll see,
the last beat of it is me kind of going up
and I don't know, I was just
bored and threw it out there.
But she jumps about three
feet high and it was great.
- I'm that person, I hate to be scared.
But I wanna see it.
- [Greg] Yeah. Good, good.
(door creaking)
(screams)
- God, why?
- God, why (laughs).
(crowd cheering)
- That is, there's no acting there.
There is no acting, that
is an authentic scare.
- She literally just yelled "God, why?"
That was amazing.
So you used to have a show just like this,
or it's sorta like this,
but did you enjoy it or
did it stress you out?
- I did. I guess I did enjoy it.
I mean, we were on really late at night
and I guess I was, you know, if you,
as long as you're person you're talking to
has answers to the questions.
- Yeah, exactly.
- It's better.
- Oh my God.
That's the one thing
whenever I first started,
I hadn't started yet.
And Seth Meyers and Jimmy Fallon,
everybody kept telling
me, like, I was like,
well what should I like,
I've never done that.
I don't know why they're giving me a show.
I was like, I don't know what's happening.
And I was like, what
should I look out for?
And they're like, it's only hard when
you get someone that just is like, yes.
And I was like, what?
I feel like I talk enough for
all humans in the room, so.
(audience applause)
I wasn't really nervous about that.
But it is funny though.
Are you really in to pop
culture enough to know it?
Because I have to do a lot of homework.
Did you?
Like, I have to do a lot of
homework with certain things,
cause I don't know everyone.
You can't possibly know everything, right?
Did you ever do that?
Did you have to do homework or no?
You're like, I just showed up (laughs).
(audience cheering)
We will edit this out (laughs).
- Yes.
- She's gonna edit it out anyway
cause I just said I have to do homework.
You're being a mute guest.
I get it, I get it, I get it.
- I had to.
You gave me, you set it up so brilliantly.
By the way, what was funny is
the longer you don't
answer Kelly Clarkson,
the longer the question is.
- I will keep going.
Cause I was searching cause
I was like, oh my god.
I didn't know if you were playing a joke
or if you were like I
actually (beep) hated it.
I was like I didn't know
which one you were doing.
- No, I just, I was seeing like how long
cause I was like wow,
this is like a two minute question.
- Welcome to being on a date with me.
I'm like I will fill the silence.
I was like, I don't like silence
- You don't like the awkward,
you don't like awkward--
- I don't like awkward.
I'm like what are you
thinking about right now?
And why aren't you saying it aloud?
You're doing it again (laughs)
- I like awkward silences Kelly.
- You like awkward silence?
That says a lot about you (laughs)